hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chest cube
again gonna play a five-minute game okay
here we go we have a 24:55 player okay
TCF the dude let's go d4 and Knight f6
all right let's see what white has up
their sleeve
I don't play d5 or c4 really matter I'm
gonna go with d5 and let's see what
light does c4 okay so since my d5 pawn
isn't challenged right now I don't think
I have any problems I think I can easily
just develop my light square bishop and
then and then lend support to my center
with moves like c6 and a six or maybe e6
first if possible so where do I go first
do I want to go to f5 or g4 that's what
I'm questioning at this point I think
I'm gonna go with f5 not not really sure
what the big difference is well actually
I think there might be c4 and then the
white queen coming out to be three to
put pressure on my b7 pawn and I didn't
want to maybe have to worry about that
Knight coming to e5 and then you'd be
hitting my bishop like that white knight
as soon as it comes to e5 I would be
hitting my bishop from g4 so we have the
offer of just the light square bishop
s-- do i just capture or maybe go back
well I think I'll just capture or mm
yeah I guess I'll just capture here
white might capture with the pawn and
then my knight doesn't have this pivot
square okay so I don't think I have any
I think it's just an equal position at
this point so what what sort of things
should I be anticipating from the white
side well right now the queen is getting
ready to come to that a be 5 square so
and that that would win the b7 pawn so
I'm gonna do c6 yeah let's go c6 e 697
or actually in 97 first just so white
doesn't get the idea of maybe planting
the knight on e5 and then it
ting pon de f4i wanted me to be able to
maybe take that night as soon as it
makes a makes it move to that e5 square
I've control over you for right now so
there's no advance of that just yet but
a white like can prep that move and
they're doing just that with that last
move so let's get my dark square Bishop
out so this is a fairly dry position not
too too much going on okay so I guess
why it's getting ready to fianchetto the
bishop and I want to make sure I have
control over this e5 square now how can
I add another defender to that point
because I'm assuming okay the bishop is
now on that diagonal indirectly
controlling this e5 square I'm thinking
either Queen c7 or actually Queen to b8
what are the differences between those
two moves I'm going to go to Queen the
BA because I'm anticipating c4 in the
opening up of the C file and I don't
want my Queen on that also in this in
this position right now if c5 I can
always come back with my bishop whereas
if I had my Queen on c7 that won't be a
possibility so white is actually getting
ready to push c5 and then start b4 b5
like a little bit of a well not a
minority attack but just expanding on
the Queen side so actually the Queen on
b8 would be supporting this advance and
well I don't know that I would actually
like that you know maybe I'm gonna play
my Bishop back in anticipation of maybe
c5 I want to make a meet this a c5
advance with maybe be b6 if I did b5
right away maybe white would play e4 and
after we exchanged a couple times my c6
pawn would then become weak so I want I
want a white to maybe first move this c4
pawn before I move my beep on okay so
now I I guess just capture yeah because
otherwise my Knights gonna get pushed
around and I don't think that I have to
do I have to capture
hmm Knight takes Knight Queen takes
Knight f6 Queen h4 and then I was
starting to have to maybe worry about my
knight on f6 but I think I can work
around that
so I'm down on time as usual it's I'm
going to support my knight I'd really
like to go for better get castled this
is an open position so and I'm not
really liking my bishop where it is
right now so maybe I want to get it to
e7 at this point so okay if I capture
the knight that's gonna be bad news for
me so let's not do that then go fish of
East 7 I just want to trade things out
ideally I want my Bishop on f6 to kind
of place this d4 pawn and a pin that
Bishop on b2 is unprotected and what
else is going on so I'm just thinking
about 97 at this point 87 I have control
over d5 and this is important because I
could push a d5 at any moment however at
this moment I'm not so sure it's good I
also have thoughts of maybe a four and
after b4 maybe B five at some point but
not just yet because c6 is in trouble by
the white knight this idea of a4 with b5
is to create a home for this night and I
think right now if I do this I think d5
turns out to be very strong so I think
I'm going to abandon that idea hmm
should I put my Bishop here I want to
try that cheese yeah let's go with that
yeah I want to go with that okay so that
Knights in a pin why probably isn't
liking that I'm down a minute move quick
and I move quick maybe I'm we gonna have
a little bit of a draw here what
how are things going to open up I may be
one of the white works can start to
swing over laterally okay now what about
hmm jeez what I do I play Queen c7 they
get my rook on the D file I want to do
that yeah I'm gonna try that
maybe uh maybe this is an okay approach
here okay I'm thinking of well actually
we might see f5 right now Oh actually
maybe I should have done a 4 B 5 and
then then I'll have that d5 square to my
night I really do have to watch about
that that Bishop on b2 could really come
to life at any moment with the d5
advance okay so maybe maybe I could
undermine this Knight now somehow so
fortunately my queen is watching over f7
that's going to I believe proved useful
I also want to think about actually c5
at this point again to undermine this a
five-night both both sides are needing a
flight square what to do
is this a four move any good I want to
get rid of this Queen maybe I should try
to get rid of that Queen let's do that
let's get them let's chase that Queen
away of Queen g5 I could do h6 attack
the Queen create a flight square for my
King and I think I think I'm alright at
this point if Luke takes stroke I'll
capture with my rook my knight is also
watching over my queen and if d5 at some
point I might want to maybe close things
up it could be a bit awkward for me
because I would have some unprotected
pieces oh I just dropped upon okay let's
let's try to attack now
I just dropped upon okay and now white
is just looking to just simplify here so
that's a that's a good thing to do now I
got to move fast I have to try and move
fast here so I'm looking to just get
into f5 to support my knight you know
what else hopefully I could start to
burn some time and okay
let's support my knight first so the
knight it could pop to that g6 square
actually we could be seeing g4 at this
point so I want to prevent that I want
to make sure I could cement that night
right there there might be some exchange
sac actually Knight f7 is a possibility
I think oh I should have done h4
actually let's let's go here
now right now right here that night was
getting ready to go to g5 so I don't
want to allow that I might see Bishop to
see one okay let's uh let's go here
maybe maybe I want to do g5 oh I don't I
just I just want a pawn there and now I
just want to go I want to get out of a
discovered attacks and let's let's trade
here trade two pair of rooks and then
get my night back there so I'm way down
on time but I think I'm think I'm still
in a good position here because I'm not
sure why am I in a good position what do
I do
well let's do this I want to create an
open a file maybe just attack that a
pond okay let's get my rook over here
doing something okay I'm gonna win this
pawn and I might be able to mate
actually I might be able to mate white
yeah white I think might end up getting
checkmated I think why it might be in
some trouble here where's that rook
gonna go hit that guy again nine-nine to
g3 this is trouble I think okay maybe
not
let's try this again if this bishop oh
I'm gaining on time fortunately so my
king is uh ooh I have to go here okay
white is just premi moving I better do
the same otherwise I might be in some
trouble okay white Wow that was down to
the wire did white lose on time what do
we have checking game and with server oh
I think white end up losing on time I
have a pre move on so I have that Wow
okay
that was another close game TCF to the
dude I was very very tight I dropped
that pawn let me just go back quickly I
dropped that pawn right there
let me see we have this is this turned
out to be pretty dry I don't I think
maybe the more pressing move at this
point right here
I'm not going to analyze this into into
depth this is just a blitz game but I
think instead just um I think just c4
actually at this point and then it makes
things a little bit more difficult to me
for me to get my light squared Bishop
out but I didn't have that problem and I
think maybe the Queen b8 move is correct
in that it you know again stays off the
C file it actually allows a potential
move like b5 how I was referencing in
the game but I completely missed that on
pon the Queen just snagging that pawn
but unfortunately I still had a knight
that was able to pivot on this efore
square so I think white did right to get
rid of the Queen's like they did but you
know it is blitz chess or even being a
pawn down you could still kind of come
back from things but uh that was
certainly a good game from TCF to dude I
once again got a pretty lucky you know
this blitz game but that's all for this
video as always I hope you're able to
take something away from it take care
bye actually you know what there is one
more thing that I wanted to add to this
video I totally forgot about it but it
involves my facebook page at
facebook.com slash chess Network and it
has to do with me analyzing someone's
game and posting it to my youtube
channel and how that would work exactly
is once you are a member of my Facebook
page and currently there's what is
approaching 5,000 members of this page
what you can then do once you're a
member of this page once you are a
licker of the page however you want to
call or whatever you want to call it
what you can then do is just make a post
to the wall and include the game
notation the the PGN along
the rating strength of both players and
maybe some other small details if you
would like but that's pretty much the
main thing right there just make a post
to the wall with the game notation and
both players ratings I'll just be
selecting someone's post and well
actually I won't be the one that's
selecting which game to analyze in a
future video but rather the people the
members of the page will be the ones who
decide on what game is to be analyzed in
a future video and how they will decide
is by giving the posts a thumbs up so
whichever post whichever game notation
is a put to this wall and receives the
most number of thumbs up that will be
the one that I go ahead and analyze in a
future video on my youtube channel so
feel free to do just that it's currently
July 3rd 2011 and you have until July
11th so that's 711 that'll be the last
day that I'll just kind of be cycling
through to see which post has received
the most number of thumbs up and that's
the one that I'll go ahead again and
analyze and post Anna as a video on my
youtube channel so that's pretty much it
if you'd like to take part in this so
feel free to do just that and we'll talk
soon